en 2023 se cumplen 100 años de la
publicación del primer libro de Jorge
Luis Borges el poemario fervor de Buenos
Aires es un libro fundacional y para los
expertos también puede ser un libro para
comenzar a leer a Borges es fundacional
porque es el primer libro que publica
Borges en lo absoluto y además en su
primer libro de poesía es fundacional
también en el sentido que lo que hablas
es constituir una estética de la poética
una especie poética de la ciudad de
Buenos Aires que en la época aparece
como una marca de identidad nacional y
en ese sentido es fundacional y creo que
hace un tiempo recomendábamos a los
lectores que empezaran por ficciones
ahora les recomendamos que empiecen por
la poesía porque porque realmente por
alguna razón un poco extraña la poesía
está como más de moda que la narrativa
ahora y para los jóvenes es más
fácilmente accesible los lectores de
Borges van mucho más allá del universo
del español existen en todo el mundo
Incluso en tan remotos como bangladesh
en mi país Ahora él es muy famoso entre
lectores
entre escritores
Yo nunca he encontrado un escritor joven
que diga no no conozco Quién es Borges
este escritor universal que es Jorge
Luis Borges será homenajeado en esta
feria del libro no solo en esta muestra
que Recuerda la publicación de su primer
libro sino también en una serie de
eventos de conferencias de charlas
dedicadas especialmente a este poemario
fervor de Buenos Aires